and quickly just gaining access you know
a wonderful neighbor someone that works
at a shop right well access is the key
to anything and you know can be on a
small level with somebody that you want
to make a documentary about and you have
a relationship with or it can be a
larger thing where you have to really
take months to gain that access on
border war we were embedded by secretary
Chertoff and met homeland security we
were embedded with a group of undercover
agents in Nogales Arizona and to get
that access took months but what that
gave the film was this incredible look
at what happens on the border with the
constant stream of human and drug
smuggling coming over and without that
access that whole section of the film
would have not not had been there than
without that really brought the viewer
into the smugglers tunnels and into the
safe houses and across the border to see
how it all happened so you know access
is everything same with broken promises
my movie on the United Nations like you
know I had to go to the United Nations
and sit down with him and convinced them
that I was going to do a film that was
going to be constructively critical of
their organization but constructive and
fair and in fact giving them the last
word which is what we did and but you
have to gain trust and get by gaining
that trust during those meetings with
the United Nations we were given access
to film in the entire facility and I
don't recall another documentary at
least before since there's been a few
feature films but we had access to film
in the General Assembly and the Security
Council rooms and and it's just full
access to the to the premises which was
invaluable and gave the film the look
that we were looking at going after so
access whether it's your neighbor or the
United Nations or department of homeland
security access isn't really what's
gonna make your story in terms of
gaining trust I think I heard John
Sayles say about mate whan that he had
to do quote the porch time he had to you
know go into the community and talk to
people and really make them realize that
he was an okay guy he wasn't there to
exploit them so what is porch time with
United Nation
I mean how do you court a relationship
like that well it was as simple as you
know calling them up and finding out
what's the protocol for proposing that
we can do a film and shoot on the
premises and you find out their
protocols and you have to write your
letters and then you have to go to New
York and you sit down with their team in
a room and you have to answer their
questions and this the bottom line is
they'll check you out and you know maybe
they think well somebody's gonna do a
film on on us I've looked and checked
into this team and we like this team and
we're gonna trust this team to do a fair
job it really comes down to that so
comes down to meeting with these people
and gaining their trust and and this was
all around an event a sixtieth
anniversary so there was going to be
some press coverage they knew was coming
and they knew they had to pick and
choose who they would allow to be in on
the premises turns out that the our film
was quite quite critical very critical
of the of the organization but it was
always meant to be you know a kind of a
meditation on how do you make it better
how do you improve it so they got that
from from our conversation and that's
why they allowed us to film there in
terms of gaining trust with some let's
say an obscure artist and you pass them
on the street and you notice them for
months how would one do that without
sort of exploiting them or is is there a
very fine line between that well you
it's always about making contact I mean
if you if you want to tell their story
they have to trust that that they're
gonna tell it in a fair fashion they
want to have they want to be able to say
I do want my story told or not if they
don't they don't but you just have to
gain you have to establish contact I
mean it's it's basically what you it's
the whole process of filmmaking is about
making connections with people too and
telling stories and exposing things to
larger groups of people so the whole
process is about communicating with
people and that begins with
communicating with your subject hello
can I make a film I'd like to make a
film about you and you'd go from there
it's almost like asking someone out on a
date so you kind of take that one that
one leap and and not as simple as that
hey man well yeah it could be as if you
know it depends on your
upper level it could be as simple
sending in the email which is fairly
safe now
like hello I'm very interested in your
story I'm a fan of your work and you
know what here's here's what I've done
in the past I mean an example recently
Errol Morris did another film with
another former Secretary of Defense this
time Donald Rumsfeld about the Iraq war
well he contacted Rumsfeld offices and
he just gave them he said look here I
made a film called the fog of war with
McNamara take a look at that you can see
if you can trust me or not come to
Washington DC and we'll film and I'll
put together a little piece and I'll
show it to you and if you like it we'll
proceed if not that's fine we'll walk
our will go our separate ways I believe
that's the way the story went but that's
the way sometimes you have to establish
trust you're not out to burn anybody
you're here to make a film and and and
and communicate and and put something
out whether it's critical or not you
know these people you want them to
cooperate with you so you want to say
I'm gonna there's no nothing no games
goin on here here's what I'm doing you
want to be a part of this and here's you
can look into my past and you can trust
me or you can not trust me that's fine
but I would like to do a film and then
you can just go from there
you